DUSTIN INGRAM: I'm Dustin
Ingram, Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
Today I'm going to
show you how you
can run a Wagtail application
on Google App Engine.
Wagtail is an open-source
content management system
built on Django.
It's used by thousands
of organizations
worldwide with a
strong community.
In fact, Wagtail on App Engine
is what powers the Google Cloud
Blog at cloud.google.com/blog.
It also looks great, is
focused on user experience,
and offers precise control for
both designers and developers.
App Engine makes it easy
to deploy your Django
app to the cloud.
And since Wagtail is
built with Django,
it's easy to get up and
running with Wagtail as well.
Also, similar to
the Django project,
Wagtail recently announced it
has dropped support for Python
2, which makes it a great
fit for the Python 3
Runtime on the App Engine
standard environment.
A content management
system consists primarily
of three parts--
an admin interface for
creating and updating
your content, a database
for storing your content,
and a frontend for
rendering your content.
Wagtail comes with its own
admin interface out of the box.
So the first thing we
need to do to get started
is create a new database
for our project.
Wagtail works with a number
of different databases.
We'll choose Postgres.
On the Google Cloud
Platform console,
we'll go to the Cloud
SQL Instances page.
Here, we'll create
a new instance
and select Postgres 9.6.
We'll just use a development
database for now,
but once your app starts
getting lots of traffic,
you'll probably want to use a
production database instead.
Next, we'll specify an instance
ID and default password.
Once the instance is
initialized, we'll select it.
Nice.
Ready to go.
Select the Copy button next
to Instance connection name
and hang onto this for later.
This string is what we'll
use to tell our app how
to connect to our database.
Now, we'll go local.
Being able to run
your app locally
makes it easier to
test changes as you're
working, without needing
to redeploy every time.
In order to run our
Wagtail app locally,
we'll need a way to connect
to the database we just
created from our local machine.
We could connect
directly to it, but this
would require that
we allow our database
to accept incoming
connections directly
from our local IP address, which
would make it slightly less
secure.
Instead, we'll use a tool
called Cloud SQL Proxy.
This is a utility that can run
on our development machine that
creates a secure tunnel between
our machine and the Cloud SQL
database.
Then we could configure our
app to talk to this local proxy
instead when running
in development mode.
Installing the Cloud
SQL Proxy is easy.
See the link in the video
description for instructions
for your platform.
We'll start the Cloud SQL
Proxy with this command.
You'll use the instance name
you copied in the previous step
here.
We'll leave this running
in a separate terminal
while we continue.
Now in a new terminal, we'll
install the Wagtail package
locally.
I'm already in a
virtual environment
that I created for this project.
If you're not familiar
with virtual environments,
see the link in the
video description
for guides for setting
up and activating
a virtual environment.
I highly recommend
that any Python project
starts with its own
virtual environment.
Installing the Wagtail package
gives us the Wagtail command,
which we can use to generate a
cookie cutter Wagtail project.
We'll call ours mysite.
So we'll use the command
Wagtail start mysite.
This will create a directory
called mysite where
our Wagtail app will live.
Let's go into that
directory and see what
our starter app looks like.
There's a few things in here
that might look familiar.
Most of the core of our
app lives in mysite.
The search and home
directories are the subpages
that we get by default. We need
to update our Wagtail's app
settings so that it has
the right information
to interact with our database.
The development settings go in a
file at mysite/settings/dev.py.
We'll tell it how to interact
with our Cloud SQL Proxy, which
should still be
running, by specifying
local host as our host.
Now we need to do the same
for our production settings.
Ideally, any secret
like a database password
would be encrypted
with an encryption key
from Cloud Key
Management Service
and held in cloud storage, only
to be decrypted at runtime.
But we'll just include our
password in the source code
here to simplify things.
But be sure to read the
guide to secret management
in the video description.
Similarly, we'll
set a secret key
which will be used for
cryptographic signing
to secure our tokens,
cookies, et cetera,
by just assigning
it in the source.
However, in production, this
should be stored as a secret
as well.
We'll also need to
tell our app which host
names it should respond to.
App Engine gives you an
appspot.com domain by default,
so we'll use that here.
Next, we're going to
migrate our database
and start up our app locally.
Since we opted to use
Postgres as our database,
we'll need to add the
psychopg2 Python package
to the requirements.text file
at the root of our project's
mysite directory.
Then let's install everything.
We'll run the migrate command
to get our database initialized.
Finally, we'll create
an administrator account
that we'll use to login
to our Wagtail app.
Running Python manage.py
createsuperuser
will prompt us for our
username and password
for our admin Wagtail user.
Now we can run Python
manage.py runserver
to start the server locally.
The Wagtail tail app will
be visible on local hosts
at port 8000 by default. Let's
check it out in our browser
by visiting
http://127.0.0.1:8000.
Once there, we should see
this generic welcome message.
Now that we have the app
configured, let's deploy it.
There's three things we
need to do before deploying.
First, we need to collect
all our static assets,
like CSS and JavaScript
into a single directory.
The collectstatic command
will do this for us.
Next we need to
create a main.py file.
This is where App Engine looks
for an app variable which
should be your application.
Wagtail puts this elsewhere and
calls it application instead,
so we just need to
connect the dots.
Finally, we need to create an
app.yaml file to hold our App
Engine configuration.
We'll tell it to use
the Python 3 Runtime,
and we'll setup handlers
for our static assets
and for our other routes.
We'll also tell it to use
our production settings once
deployed.
When we're done,
our mysite directory
should look something like this.
Now all we need to do is
deploy with gcloud app deploy.
Once the deployment
is finished, we
can go visit our app at
its URL on appspot.com,
and we'll see that same
familiar welcome screen.
We can also sign in with
the super user account
that we created before.
Looking great.
We've got a content
management system.
Now all that's left to
do is add the content,
which is easy with
Wagtail's web interface.
From here, you might
also want to start
working on your app's
frontend to create a more
engaging experience
for your visitors,
or add some models to begin
defining your business logic.
I've shown you how to set
up a Cloud SQL database,
create a new Wagtail project,
and deploy it to App Engine's
new Python 3 Runtime.
And I'm confident that you'll
be able to take this and build
something great on Google Cloud.
The best part about
App Engine is that it
grows with your application.
When you aren't getting
traffic, you don't pay anything.
And as your app becomes more
popular and traffic increases,
it scales automatically
to meet that demand.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
I'll show you how
to use Stackdriver
to monitor your Python 3 app.
Feel free to ask questions
in the comments below.
And if you liked
this video, please
subscribe to the Google
Cloud Platform channel
for more videos like this.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]